[Music]
[Applause]
luna
the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
guys and welcome back to the leia
highlands show powered by icon
plus capital the vc firm as always it is
sponsored by blockfy you can get up to
when you sign up so that is pretty cool
um before we jump in i do have a new
sponsor this month so i just want to let
you guys know
who it is otherwise we won't be able to
have these amazing conversations so
this episode is sponsored by compass
mining
the company that makes bitcoin money
accessible for everyone you just buy
your machine
pick a hosting facility and let them do
the work so
if you want to start mining bitcoin then
you just need to head to compass
mining.io
which is pretty cool because mining
bitcoin is expensive
so joining me today is bernard parra the
ceo
of bit knob bernard welcome to the show
i can see that you are on mute so just
unmute yourself
oh no do we have do we have a connection
problem
let's see maybe if i remove bernard and
bring him back in
okay so while we try and get bernie to
come back in
basically today is a really interesting
show we
are talking about bitcoin in nigeria um
there are a lot of different
restrictions um and problems and
a lot of reasons people are turning to
bitcoin um in this part of the world so
i wanted to get bernard on the show
but it looks like we're having a problem
all right maybe i will drop him a
message
and see what is up
i'm having really bad luck with uh with
my live shows oh there we go is he back
bernard we can't really hear you or see
you
okay guys let me know if it's me or
bernard okay i think it's
can you hear me okay i'm having a lot of
bad luck with my shows i actually had
um michaela peterson on the other day
and um as soon as we were talking about
tick tock
the show just crashed well she had a
power cut which was totally random
okay i think we have bernard back let's
have a look there we go
what happened i think i lost my
connection but i'm good
you're good so welcome to the show how
are you
ah thank you how are you doing i'm good
i'm glad that i have you back i was
stressing for a moment
how are you yeah i'm good
happy to be here yeah well listen
i came across your profile because i saw
you did this long tweet which totally
blew up i think he got
around 14 000 likes um talking about
why bitcoin is really really necessary
in nigeria
um so before we jump into that tell us a
little bit about yourself because you
are obviously the ceo of bitknob so
tell us about that yeah yeah so
thank you for having me once again um my
name is bernard para
ceo and co-founder of bidnog software
engineering background
you know and we've been what we're doing
is basically you know um
reducing the barrier to access uh you
know bitcoin and um you know
cryptocurrencies like stable coins
to nigerians and africans at large you
know
um over time it's been like
really expensive for people to get these
assets um you know
do you have peculiar challenges over
here and whatnot and
we believe that democratizing access to
assets like this
it's a really important mission and
that's that's the most important thing
for us right now
and what we're doing at bit knob yeah i
think it's honestly amazing so
um for those that don't know um burn it
is based in nigeria right now
and one of the main things that got me
really hooked on this space
and i say this all the time was how and
i will say blockchain technology
and bitcoin is essentially saving lives
in many different parts of the world
creating better quality of life
helping people giving them an economic
fighting chance
that is actually what really hooked me
so from your perspective i really want
to know if you could just break it down
for us what are some of the key problems
in nigeria
and why you feel you need a new system
yeah i think the first one is um capital
controls currency controls
so for example right now you can't
really use more than a hundred dollars
you know uh out of your debit card to
you know buy things online so just
think about it you've you've gone to
work you've earned some money and
um you know you can you can't even spend
it online right you need to you know
find ways around that
which is not good it's basically taking
your freedom from you um you know the
other things are things like inflation
so nigeria's inflation is currently at
um
16.5 percent that's like that's absolute
that's very high
right um nigeria's the nigerian era has
lost
i mean more than 30 percent of its value
against the us dollar in the past one
year
um it's really crazy so in real time
we're seeing the cost of things going up
and it's just it just looks like there's
no way out right
and um bitcoin just gives us that kind
of alternative
and of course investment opportunities
as well so
of course everyone is looking to get
wealthy um
but to get things like stocks and all of
those things are kind of pretty
expensive
for every but for everyone to get in
right uh things like bitcoin bitcoin
just democratizes that
access to it you can easily exchange it
as an asset with anyone
around the world and you know and we're
seeing pretty interesting things as well
around the censorship resistance space
so we've seen people's uh bank accounts
getting locked
because they were blocked because he did
something maybe the government doesn't
want
and it's basically just taking your
freedom that's basically just taking
your freedom away from
you when you look at it so fundamentally
uh
bitcoin is um freedom to to us it gives
us that alternative
uh to the current system
okay so here's my thing you mentioned
three really
insane things okay firstly
i'm just gonna repeat this in case
anybody didn't catch because your
internet is going
in and out um a bit so bernard was
saying that
there is a 100 a day limit
on online spending a month
a month oh my god a month i'm sorry i
missed that
why my thing is why why how is that
justified
i mean it's um it's basically forex
controls right so for these banks to
make those international payments for
you
they need to find um you know they need
to get the dollar equivalent
to make those international payments for
you so basically just capital controls
that
uh to reduce the outflow of um dollars
from the economy
wow honestly i'm really taken back i
didn't realize i thought it was
i thought it was a day so thank you for
clarifying that
so inflation is around 16
why is that happening
i think it's a it's a couple of factors
so the first factor is um
nigeria is more of a consuming economy
right
um we import we import almost everything
right um from china from the u.s
muslim imports driven uh economy and um
also a huge part of our gdp as well you
know
it's based on oil and we know how the
oil
prices have been in the past um yeah
as well so you look at other government
policies for example
um in the past one two years the
government locked uh closed
down the borders so you couldn't really
you know you can't import things
so they there's this rice in food
because food inflation itself is like
more than 20 percent as we speak
right so of course there's food
production is low within the country
uh you can't really import things as
well from abroad
it's really expensive to do that um
getting effects as well depleting
foreign reserves
you know just a lot of factors that just
you know
make it just uh it's just crazy just
those are like key factors mostly
government policies
but what i don't understand is like when
you look at the country and you look at
these spending limits and you look at
how it's badly affecting people's lives
you know in terms of entrepreneurship
and just being able to do business with
the rest of the world
which is so important you know to
basically just changing your life
why would they make it so difficult it
sounds like it's done on purpose
i mean am i missing something here for
me i just i can't understand why
i mean about control i'm sorry if it's
unfair but is it about control
um so so we we like to think of it in
two ways down here in africa right um
we like to see them first as a failure
of leadership right basically
you know you know um certain set of
people
just wanting to stick to the old way of
doing things not wanting to
you know move uh with the time with the
times and everything
and of course there's a part of control
right yeah when you look at on the nsa's
protest as well and
uh why people's accounts were getting
blocked uh you know for contributing
for donating to the process was it was a
thing of control right because it looked
like ah this
this young guys are coming to you know
move us out of of power and everything
that's what he saw he saw that's a power
as a power game right yeah and um when
jack tweeted about bitcoin
and you know it just kind of spooked
them and like
took them to the next level of fear
anxiety and everything and then their
actions
from then on where are like really
brutal so there's aspect of control and
when you look at it
uh bitcoin basically is coming to take
you know control out of
you know existing systems like this
right to give you an
alternative to opt out of these systems
so so that's that's a bit in control and
just uh you know old man
sticking to the audio of doing things
yeah i mean
i've spoken to um a lot of different
ceos based out of nigeria because
there are a lot of people in this
industry trying to help and make a
better life and every single time i hear
about this
i you know it just really blows my mind
and it really warms my heart that
there's a solution truly
um so from your standpoint when did you
first hear about bitcoin
well sometime in uh i think november of
um long time ago yeah yeah
but how what happened um
yeah so first first i saw it online i
think um
if i remember correctly something around
all these silk road um case and stuff
raws and all of that and then um
later i heard one of my classmates in
school talking about it
you know and it's like he's got some
bitcoin and stuff i'm like uh how does
he do it what does he do is like he
sells it he makes money uh from
it's right and i'm like oh cool um so i
had done all that
kind of um digital stuff before liberty
reserve all those kind of things so
the concept of selling digital
currencies online basically just clicked
and started getting some from him and
also reselling
i basically just kept on doing that uh
you know before
you know sometime in 2016 started
building um you know crypto applications
bitcoin applications
uh you know for companies around here
yeah so
is it difficult then is it difficult to
build a
cryptocurrency business in nigeria are
there restrictions
yeah it's um it's very difficult the
funny thing is at a point in time it
felt like the easiest thing to do
right oh yes there were no um there were
no
clear-cut regulations you didn't need
any special kind of license
you need to adjust it free for all you
know just set up your website
and just get people to trust you and
come and buy bitcoin from and
that was it right um it felt like the
easiest thing to do
but right now you know when you do it
you're on your own right so you can't
get
uh official banking partnerships so you
can't have an official bank account here
you can't you know have a payment
processor helping you collect
uh funds you know servers on-ramp or
off-ramp for you
so it's um it's really difficult it just
keeps getting more difficult but um
i mean we're welding a lot we're
learning to be more anti-fragile and you
know just build
for the world yeah the restrictions
um have become more intense in nigeria
um
and this year particularly it really
sparked my interest because
there was a ban right the ban was that
major well not even major just
institutional banks
weren't allowed to on board sorry
weren't allowed to
facilitate cryptocurrency exchanges but
apparently that
but then somebody came out and sort of
said well actually no that's not true it
was just
reinforcing something from a few years
ago so there's been a lot of u-turns
it's confusing can you explain what the
current regulations are and what you can
and can't do
yeah i mean i mean um the first of such
kind of um
you know what they call it warnings or
guidance was
yeah sometimes sometime in 2017 if
i remember correctly or late yeah 2016
when um the
mmm uh who this ponzi scheme called mmm
was very
you know come on down here right and
according to central bank that's just
what they've been doing they've just
been reiterating that
um this is not officially recognized in
the country and
you know they've never actually went out
like
directly to see you know financial
institutions shouldn't do anything with
crypto companies right
but um this time so they didn't say that
oh this time they did it right yeah
they did this time they did this decent
day the guardians was really clear that
uh looking for a payment processor you
can overcome with crypto companies
uh as well so i mean
right now of course bitcoin
cryptocurrencies are not illegal in
nigeria you can still
trade you can still use them for your
transactions
you consider whatever you want to do
with them but
if for example you are starting an
exchange you can't have a bank account
you can have a payment processor there
are no
as it stands there still no clear-cut
regulations
right from the sec yeah it's kind of um
we're seeing different tones from the
sec the central bank
and the ministry of information and
technology
it's really kind of these ones are
looking this way and these ones are
looking this way
and then it's it's they're just dilly
dilling like there's
really no clarity when it comes to
distance right now
i think that's the point though isn't it
to make it really difficult just off
topic for a second
sort of reminds me with what's going on
in the uk with kovid they've made it so
difficult to understand
what the travel rules are and the travel
restrictions are so you just don't end
up getting involved
because one person says this another one
says that so you just give up entirely
um so how do you buy business yes
yeah it is it's it really
really is just make things as confusing
as possible
yeah um unbelievable so how do you buy
bitcoin then yeah so
um of course the most popular way of
buying bitcoin right now is um
you know peer-to-peer transactions um
either on
platforms or in whatsapp groups or just
someone you know directly right but wait
sorry yeah
throw it into rupturing but that would
require somebody else in nigeria to want
to sell their bitcoin
what if they don't want to i mean um
if you go to platforms that
you know all these transactions like
paxo you're definitely going to get
someone who
who is looking to sell some bitcoin for
you right either the person is doing
some form of remittances
through paxful wants to liquidate their
bitcoin for fiat
you definitely get someone who wants to
do it and of course there are a lot of
groups as well
uh you know where they've been there for
a long time some since 2016 they've been
there
there's that reputation you can just go
in and that means
you know if we facilitate a trade
between you and whoever
um the other way is um and that's
one of the things we use at bitno is um
uh through vouchers
so people just buy um these digital
vouchers and then are able to redeem it
for bitcoin so those are like the two
major ways um people can actually buy
bitcoins uh
in nigeria right now i'd love to hear
your thoughts about
i guess really just global sentiment
towards bitcoin because
it's heating up i mean even in the uk
the restrictions are
just getting worse um you know you can't
you that finance um and barclays bank
have now had an issue between them
um yeah i believe you i believe you
can't actually even send from buying uh
from barclays sorry to finance anymore
so yeah do you believe that bitcoin
could ever be banned
um i mean you can't ban bitcoin right um
i don't believe you can ban bitcoin
you can't you can't you can't do that
like from day one
bitcoin is global from day one bitcoin
is censorship resistant
like you know uh the genius of satoshi
you know it's kind of
just looked at what are the
possibilities and what's not right
it's literally almost impossible to do
that right now
you know if you want to do a 51 attack
it's very expensive to do that
right and um we're seeing mining as well
becoming more decentralized so i see
yeah
miners moving out of china you know into
other jurisdictions
uh and if you look at it in the short
term it's looking like a bad thing
but you know the longer term outlook is
that um this is a good thing right
so you have more miners in russia you
have miners in the u.s you have miners
moving into europe uh
other parts of asia like i think
i think i think you know more than ever
it's solid find a
future of bitcoin that bitcoin cannot be
banned right you can't
go to china and just get most of the
miners off the network of course we have
the difficult
uh t uh algorithm that also adjust that
adjust automatically as well
so i don't think they can do that um i
think that we try
um i think that's like a huge war that
will come
you know especially when the stats are
launching their cbdc's
and what's not right um but well i think
i think bitcoin is
it's in good hands um the people the
people will surely be on the side of
bitcoin
it's not going to be easy but then i'm
sure that uh
whole conca yeah it's so fascinating
um because you're totally right you know
you have the decentralized network i'm
totally on the same side of that
um you know you can't actually ban that
and if
one country were to ban it or you know
increase hostility like we saw in china
then they just moved right so that's
totally fine
and i think what also blew my mind was
that um
so for people that don't know luno they
actually sponsor this podcast
and they um are a uk and they're also
based in nigeria their cryptocurrency
exchange
and we spoke about this a few months ago
and i actually double checked with luno
this is a fact
so when they did um when nigeria did
that clampdown
and bitcoin started to trade at a
premium on luno
mind-blowing that's crazy yeah i mean
we love that there's there's there's
demand there's this there's always
so right now um you know unlike um
earlier yes uh right now with bitcoin
you know if you send bitcoin to me over
here in nigeria i could um
there are so many ways for me to
liquidate it in like less than 10
minutes right and having around my bank
account
like um since i've moved so fast um
you know you have a vibrant community of
people using
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies for
you know remittances whatever they want
to use it for
and um i think times have changed and
just to you know just to
go back like a minute to a minute ago to
what we're talking about um
i did centralization of bitcoin now it's
it's not that
uh bitcoin it's it's uh in a way also
it's kind of like a jubilee school tool
right that if one country tries to ban
it
right or move miners out of it another
country is going to take advantage of
that
and that's what we're seeing right now
with with china china is
saying hey leave our country and all of
that and there are many countries
saying hey come like accepting them and
you know doing
uh just giving them the best uh you know
of um services to you know set up their
that
their cause uh in their country so i
think it's gonna be
uh you know even in geopolitical space
uh
bitcoin has that um thing to you know
put one country
you know hey you want to sanction me
then yeah i'm going into bitcoin right
i look at the case of el salvador and
all of those kind of things so i think
um
i think we're gonna have interesting
times
yeah i mean el salvador you bring that
up that's a fascinating one isn't it
because
they're so small right they're a tiny
country with just over a population of
just over six
million people the amount of hostility
that they have received
from the u.s from global organizations
from i kind of get into it right now
it's just it just blows my mind you know
it just really shows you the power of
bitcoin
um and how people know that's where you
know that's that's the thing i think
authorities know um but you mentioned
cbdc's
and nigeria are working on one aren't
they
yeah i had sue um and you know it's just
just like everyone i'm just i'm just
waiting to see
what what comes of of it right um just
waiting to see what comes of it it's
kind of
you know we're not gonna let this happen
but then we're doing it so is it a case
of just
doing what everyone says they're doing
or is this a case of do you really
believe in this thing that you're
talking about
and you know so yeah i think sometimes
yeah they'll do it
no but the thing is i think they'll do
it everybody's gonna do it
china's already um you know china's
already moving ahead with theirs i think
theirs is already actually active in
beijing i saw some news about it today
actually which wasn't good but anyway
um i mean this is sort of control so
they don't
definitely want to do it yeah oh yeah
yeah
no absolutely and for those that don't
know it's simply because it's going to
be
um highly centralized that is the
problem it's going to be highly
centralized
and um you speak about this war between
the two i'd love to hear
more about that because i also share a
really similar um opinion
so tell me more about that war that you
sort of envisage
uh yeah so uh i mean if you're talking
about the war between the nation state
and
bitcoin or between two nation states uh
with yeah so um when we're talking about
the war between nation states and
bitcoin right
um it's really more of uh
which country is gonna come all out to
actually show that this particular
technology
is uh undermining their control
right now yeah um i mean we've seen
glimpses of that with china
right yeah uh we've seen this of that
with china china is trying to
uh their cbdc is coming out and you know
suddenly they are moving bitcoin
uh miners out of china because one thing
about cb diseases is that
once they go live and people discover
that these are actually true
tools of control and more oppression
then
people are going to even want to opt
in to things like bitcoin the more
because
right now asides bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies
what you have is cash is like the next
private
thing that we have with money there's
nothing wrong with privacy i think
that's that's part of the thing that
they you know they fail to understand
there's nothing wrong with privacy
you know i mean i don't have to be doing
anything bad
right to demand privacy you know
what i had for breakfast today you know
it's my personal business
right i only i can only choose to let
you know if i want to right but is it a
bad thing that i had my breakfast
you know no it's not a bad thing so
i think that you know when they start
doing these things um a lot of more
people come to the consciousness
that um we've been controlled for so
long
and if this were actually doing central
bank
digital currencies it means that there's
something in these digital currencies
you know so what's the difference
between bitcoin and these ones right
now when they bring out their central
bank digital currencies of course
uh they wouldn't want it to coexist with
bitcoin rights because i mean that's the
anticipation of whatever they're doing
and
however they do it no matter how they do
it the clear difference between
their uh coins and bitcoin is the
monetary policy they're not going to
change their monetary policy
it's just in fact if anything it allows
them to mean
more money much easier you know at the
press of a button
they've maintained much more much more
money so
i think that you know there's going to
be a coordinated effort um you know
between these countries
uh to yeah you know uh fight against
bitcoin and
even i i see that um as well you have
these bigger countries and more
developed countries who control the
likes of imf
uh you know trying to put pressure on
smaller countries so like what's in
return el salvador
right uh you probably see you'll
probably see them telling african
countries that maybe
one of the demands one of the conditions
in which we're going to give you
a loan or a grant or whatever is that
you know you have to bank bitcoin in
your country and you know
they probably just do it yeah i mean
it's not impossible it's it's it's
something that you can do
we have to be able to think of the whole
worst case scenario because when you see
the comments that come
from these people then you see that like
really
i mean just see what happened with
somebody just showed your hands
anyone that was doubting right this was
clear right
and bitcoin is a central bank bitcoin is
actually
we think of bitcoin as so many things
but we forget that bitcoin is actually
also fighting against central banking
because bitcoin himself is a central
bank right but
one central bank one monetary policy
that doesn't change
that you know doesn't discriminate that
everyone across the world
someone in the u.s cannot tell me not to
use bitcoin
you know or tell me how to use my
bitcoin right it doesn't discriminate
but someone in the u.s
can tell me how to use my nara which is
what is happening right now
because through setting government
policies through imf through the world
bank
who controls money in my country right i
can't
that that whole thing trickles down to
me so the whole council on the effects
and everything industry cools down to me
but with bitcoin this is like totally
different so i think it's going to be
interesting in the next decade most
especially
yeah i mean i don't think a lot of these
countries have africa's best interests
at heart
no no no they have i did come on they
know i did
never have they never they probably
never will so yeah
yeah exactly so to be able to have a
currency which is independent from these
con
these countries um and their sanctions
and their blackmail
and all these sorts of fun things all
these exciting tools of control
um it's pretty insane but you made a
point about um
people will see the truth in cbdc's and
then
pick bitcoin but i disagree um
i have a concern um that cbdc's will be
marketed as this
new shiny piece of technology that will
save the day
obviously you and i and everybody
watching know that that obviously knows
that that's not the case um
but i worry that they'll think because
right now people do think bitcoin is
kind of criminal so when they look to
cbdc's they'll be like
oh this is better it's government-backed
you know it's supported by the
government the government says this is
okay
so education is going to be really
important don't you think
yeah yeah um i quite agree with them
with some you know your thoughts on that
i mean uh obviously it's even the same
thing right now that's happening with
bitcoin right
um a lot of people still think it's used
for just criminal purposes it's a bad
thing
and what's not and it's because we have
taken time to understand it you know do
the research
ask questions and we've seen it right so
of course what i was trying to say was
with the cb disease you're gonna have uh
people who are also gonna see this
not everyone but it's gonna be the
trigger point
for you know another set of people
to leave to want to opt out of that
system because
they probably fall victim of you know uh
you know noun they don't have cash
because one thing disabilities is
they're going to try to eliminate cash
there's a war on cash they're still
ongoing
i believe that when cbc's come they're
going to accelerate that war on cash
right now when that one cash goes then
uh you know
it's it becomes a whole thing and uh of
course you can displace the part of um
education i think education is really
important
uh you know people have to understand
why the whys of
money at uh in the first place because
for someone the fact that he has
one thousand error in his bank account
uh today and he comes up to it
12 months later and he still one
thousand error that's what matters to
the person
person doesn't care about purchasing
power the person doesn't care about
inflation and whatnot
we have to be able to get people to see
that this is not just
uh as it is this is not just what they
tell you right
like there's something behind it and i
think um
as everyone the community we are
about to you know put put put a lot of
effort uh
into you know educating people which is
what i keep saying that uh the most
important work for everyone right now
is for us to um on board as many people
as we can
before this war comes because when this
war comes we're gonna need the numbers
we're gonna need
the wealth to uh fight this was gonna be
fights of misinformation and all of that
kind of thing
so so that's how i see it playing out i
tell you bernard i think the war has
started
it has started i'm telling you i feel it
um
but what's what's the education um like
um in nigeria when it comes to bitcoin
do people know much about it is there
this
kind of concern and fear around it that
we certainly have in the uk
i think people think bitcoin and crypto
is just some kind of
weird dirty thing yeah i i think um
so so from you know my own personal
experience uh
talking to people um you know those who
have never gotten and all of that
um it's more of i think less
less from the criminal uh you know
aspect of it
it's more of that fear of even starting
you know how does it even work like yeah
i i wanna put just ten dollars in it
like but how does even work
right they have no clue how it works
right and
you know sometimes you go on google but
they prefer someone explains it to them
and they get it to do because assistance
nigeria is a very low trust environment
so typically i would want someone who is
doing it to want to
maybe probably take me through it right
of course we have groups so we have we
have people who do it as a business
right teaching people about bitcoin
what cryptocurrencies and well i think
they've i think generally they've
actually done a fantastic job of
onboarding people
uh into the space right even if they
charge i mean
they gotta eat right but um i think
they've done i think
i think that they're kind of some of the
unsung heroes
when it comes to onboarding people uh
you know onto bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies uh in nigeria so these
people have groups
they probably educate like maybe 20
people a month 30 people a month
uh you know even if people pay yeah
right and then they keep they keep those
groups growing mentoring people in there
and you know they're not out there
people don't know that people don't see
them but you know yeah
again they're doing the legwork and and
we're just banking on that network
effect that
you know if i see this person doing it
and he has taught me i'm also going to
go and start my own group
and teach other people and you know and
then it grows um that way
yeah it's great to hear that there's
some education um
i want to actually ask you about um
other cryptocurrencies
in nigeria because i mentioned earlier
that i have spoken to
a lot of guys who are building their own
protocols with their own protocols come
their own tokens and their own cryptos
so
um what how do i put this what else is
going on
is there any interest in anything else
um i know somebody's actually written in
the comments
people want to make quick money right so
the next thing they hear if elon musk is
talking about dodge coin
you know uh people in the community
probably
feel like okay this guy is just um just
naming
dodge coin and stuff but people actually
take him serious
right right people knew to this place
actually take him really serious
and you know um i'm just remembering the
whole dutch coin creed who are
in as well um the shebai you have
someone think
i have one million shiva and you know
that's probably lost value right now you
know
and it's just uh crazy i mean for a lot
of them first time
of course um for a lot of us first time
we got him we go bonds um so i i guess
it's just
learning our lessons and doing but
they're interesting projects as well
coming out of nigeria
so of course there's um send finance so
basically yeah
those are the guys cooperative unions
so they're doing cooperative unions are
you know on the blockchain with their
own stuff
bundle is doing amazing stuff you know
um you know they've kind of unlocked
some kind of growth marketing in the
space and kind of
you know blew up really fast uh you have
bicones you know
uh luna since the band luna hasn't been
uh really active in nigeria i mean
back then they were really like you know
uh probably the biggest
you know because they rely on the banks
right
yes yes yes yes um yeah and of course
there's paxful right so
of course on the information to to parks
for right um you know a lot of people
just probably just like
run their businesses uh on top of that
uh
as well so yeah these coins are there
finance you know finance you know almost
everyone has
the finance out they just trade their
tokens
and you know that kind of thing but i
think it's interesting i'm seeing people
getting into
uh there's this group called um web free
breach
i think they are teaching people how to
build on ethereum and
just technical uh development and you
know people just uh
there are a couple of interesting
projects um around so yeah
yeah that is interesting so how's
ethereum um what's the ethereum
sentiment are people interested in that
i mean i know it's
not really regarded as the store of
value but given web three is uh is that
quite popular
yeah yeah i think it's quite popular
over here in nigeria so
um for a lot of people they hold bitcoin
and ethereum right
you have the guys who tell that you know
html is gonna flip i have one friend
that
has been telling me how to run with
flipped bitcoin for the past three years
you know
he's gonna flip this so ethereum has a
really strong um community over here in
nigeria
and um i think um in fairness to them
they have
more developers going into uh trying to
build
d5 applications and trying to build um
smart contracts on
material you know trying to integrate it
into everyday finance
and whatnot so i think it's pretty big
here
yeah this is a thing so for me bitcoin
is
the store of value um you know i would
tell people to buy bitcoin but i would
never ever tell them to buy anything
else
um but i am i'm bullish on ethereum um
mainly because um sorry i have a fan and
it's blowing everything because it's
very hot
and um yeah so i'm really really bullish
on ethereum just because i feel like the
entire internet is attempting to
be built on ethereum i'm not saying that
it's going to be but it's attempting to
and especially in africa you know when
it comes to
decentralized finance lending and
borrowing i mean
it's like a no-brainer that that to me
that also was something which just blew
my mind um
no not yet um even though apart from zen
finance of course right yeah
um i mean i personally feel that you
know a lot of
distance can still be built on bitcoin
right but just as you're saying
uh you can't you can't you can't you you
can't displace
network effects right i think ethereum
has strong network effects um
in nigeria as well right so you can't
really displace and say hey look
just go to the gutters you know you're
not gonna of course i i don't tell
people to buy ethereum i don't tell
people to buy any other
tokens or whatever it's just purely uh
bitcoin just like you right
but of course you can't ignore this you
can't um ignore uh stable coins
the fact that stable coins run on a
serial man you know people people always
get surprised when i tell them that you
know something like tita
actually started on the bitcoin
blockchain right on
what they call it only i forgotten the
name of the
project right so um people people are
really bullish on that people want to
build all these
smart contracts people feel that there
are a lot of things that they can build
on top of
ethereum to do things for them and you
have
actually more developers going into
building ethereum applications
uh over here learning how to of course
uh personally i would prefer that you
know we have more developers going into
bitcoin where
i feel that we need to do more work uh
on that
um you know i think chain could have
started something similar
around that side but um i think uh when
it comes to developers
it has been taken personally i did
something with um consensus studios in
uh to build um ethereum stuff right um
you know the antideveloper academy stuff
and so it's kind of it's taking the lead
when it comes to getting developers out
of nigeria out of africa
essentially that bitcoin we need to kind
of do to catch up as well
hopefully we lighten it as well yeah
it's it's so amazing i'm
i just i just love it like i love a good
solution you know to a problem which is
just
feels so unfixable unsolvable like a
lifetime kind of problem you know
um so thank you so much like honestly
it's been so fascinating learning uh
more about this from you um
where can people learn more about you
and what are you up to next
um okay so people can find me on twitter
bernard on the para
p-a-r-a-h or just search for uh bidding
up
uh b-i-t-n-o-b on twitter i'm sure that
my name come on you know
under people you can find me there uh
big-nub and we're working on a couple of
interesting things
so working on bringing um lightning uh
you know to to nigeria and to other
africans
uh you know very soon yeah in the next
couple of weeks you know you can be able
to send
you know even just one dollar worth of
bitcoin from anywhere in the world
down to nigeria you know instantly
for like a penny uh you know so i'm
really excited about that
um yeah we have a couple of other things
coming um
interest on savings um you know i
people are really picking up the gta
because i'm picking up championed
dc in africa and we're really seeing
people you know are
loving it and doing more dc as well so
yeah i'm really
those are those are the things we're
working on and you know just want to
push
more to see how things go yeah i think
it's all
so amazing um you know i really
appreciate the work that you're doing
um thank you for me this has just been
the the thing like i said at the
beginning which just grabbed me and
pulled me into the space and made me
stay the
opportunities and not just for people um
in nigeria and the rest of africa but
for everyone really um you know it's
just it's just opportunity to be honest
um
so bernard i want to thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure having you
um and it's been so great to get your
insight given you're literally based
in nigeria right now so thank you so
much i enjoyed the chat thank you for
having me
bye yeah and guys thank you so much for
watching
um what i will do is um if you are based
in nigeria and you do want to buy
bitcoin i will leave
a luna link for you um i'll ask the guys
we'll get one i think they could
potentially do something where you get
like ten dollars i'm not 100 sure
um but i'll speak to them and i'll try
and leave the link in um
the youtube description so thanks so
much for watching please don't forget to
subscribe
so you never miss an amazing video and i
will see you all next week
bye bye